say my name
Heisenberg
you're damn right whoo that just took me
back guys Breaking Bad was a show that
people obsessed over on the small screen
but could be headed to the big screen
variety has confirmed yes the creator
Vince Gilligan is working on a new film
with ties to the iconic series Breaking
Bad went off the air in 2013 sorry even
5 years it's time we are ready for a
Breaking Bad movie get us back in the
desert and God who doesn't want Bryan
Cranston their lives more
speaking of though this got us to
thinking as we love to do brainstorm
about entertainment here's some other TV
shows we think should have become movies
scandal okay we lost this one more
recently and ended in April of this year
but who doesn't need Olivia Pope in our
lives again and can you imagine her
wardrobe with a big big film budget yes
please pretty little liars
it ended in June of last year Annie
t-zone Kelty night was with star Shan
Mitchell Shay says she's on board for a
movie take a look so how soon can we
have the pre Liars movie or reunion you
never know I guess it depends on the
writers in the cast
you know I am also a big fan Sex in the
City when they came out with their
movies I was like this is awesome yeah
you know I think we could be open to
that five 10 years running cool Golden
Girls okay so that could really happen
we've already gotten a spin-off series
next up oh people are obsessing with
this show now that it's Benja belong
streaming the office okay we would take
a TV reboot we would take a movie reboot
we would take it all Michael Scott's but
here's the thing here's what Steve
Carell has to say about bringing it back
to TV unless you had exactly the same
cast and exactly the same group of
writers and you know that that whatever
that chemistry was between everybody to
try to recreate it just wouldn't you
know I don't I think people would be
disappointed you know what though Steve
I think that we could make it happen
because you're a movie star now that's
us talking to you at a movie junket and
John Krasinski is a movie star now so
just get everybody together for a movie
okay people are in again the office is
getting a new life on Netflix and now
so tweet us let us know everyone what TV
shows of yours that have gone by the
wayside would you like to see mean into
movies tweet us Aditi now
[Music]
[Applause]